저희가 이번에 연남동에 또 리모델링한
현장이 좀 있어요
기존에 원래 되게 낡은 단독주택으로
제가 기억을 했는데 어떻게 좀
리모델링을 했는지
기존의 지하 1층 그 다음에 지상
2층 규모의 단독주택이었고요 일본은
벽돌 타이어 그리고 조적 벽돌이라고
하는 마감으로 되어있던 예전
단독주택이었습니다
기존에도 한번
페인트칠을 하셔 가지고
외관만 좀 변경을 하셨었는데 이번에
전체적인 용도를 바꾸고
변경을 하면서 거기에 맞게끔 또
디자인을 조금 변경을 했어요 그래서
기존의 주택 같은 경우에는 실의
위치에 따라 또 실의 크기에 따라
이제 창문에 위치나 크기들이
조금씩 제한적으로
될 수밖에 없는데 아무래도 상가로
변경을 하다 보니까 좀 개방감 있는
것들을 서로 하시다 보니 좀 큰
창문들로
변경을 했고
기존 주택에서 활용하던 발코니들은
상가에서 좀 외부 공간으로 활용하실
철거하지 않고 재활용을 했습니다 그게
어떻게 보면 가장 좋은 거 같아요
유지하면서 있는 것들을 좀 재활용할
수 있는 방안으로 설계를 해보자
접근을 했었어요
기존과는 최대한 살려두고 그리고 이제
특히 계단 같은 경우에는 또 이제
새로 만들면 또 비용이 또 많이
들거든요
기간도 또 많이 들고 그래서 어떻게
보면 이번에 사례는 좀 기존에 있던
걸 최대한 좀 살려는 그런 사례라고
보시면 될 것 같고 일단은 제가 딱
그 연트로파크에서 들어왔을 때 바로
앞에 있어요 여기서 바로 연트로파크가
보일 정도로 이렇게 상권이 원래 이제
기존에 다 단독주택이었는데
계속 바뀌어 나가는 위치 딱 들어왔을
때 좀 제가 봤을 때 제일 좀 눈에
띄어요
밝은 건물들이 많지 않다 보니까 오래
건물은 좀 밝아서
눈을 더 띄는 효과가 있는 것
같습니다네
들어왔는데 가장 눈에 띄는게 이제
보강을 했네요네
철골 구조로 기둥과
구조 보강을 했고요
기존의 주택으로 사용을 했었다 보니
실들이 벽돌로 다 보이게 돼 있었는데
그런 부분들을 다 철거하고 한
공간으로 사용하실 수 있게 구조공항이
되어 있습니다
기존의 층고가 많이 낮았어요
그래서 바닥에 있던 마감도 다 철거를
하고
했지만 지금도 보시는 것처럼 좀
층고가 높지 않은 편이에요 그래서
구조보가 보통 저희가 20cm에서
25cm짜리 크기의
오래 사용을 하는데 나중에 마감이
어떻게 될지는 모르겠지만 보호
밑으로는 2.1m에서 2.2m 정도
높이가 확보되는 상황입니다 다
이동하시는데 간섭되거나 그러진 않고요
그리고 여기가 지금 집안 도로보다
조금 레벨이 낮아요 그래서 원래는이
공간이 지하였었어요 그랬는데
원래 지하층이라고 하면
집안에서 이제 절반 이상이 묻혀
있어야 지하층으로 인정받을 수 있는데
그거보다는
조금 더 노출 많이 돼 있던
상황이었습니다 그래서 저희가
대수산화가를 진행을 하면서이 부분을
지하층으로 인정을 받지 못했고 그래서
지상 1층으로
추인을 하는
과정에서
그런 이제
층수 부모에 대한 추인이 진행이
이뤄지면서
이행강제금이
예전 건물들은 다 이제 지하로
인정받은게 되게 많잖아요 그래서 그게
실제로 2분의 1정도 묻혀가 있는지
지하 1층으로 인정받을 수 있는지
없는지가 어떻게 보면
리모델링 할 때 되게 중요한
요소겠네요
신축을 할 때는 다
철거를 하기 때문에 그게 이슈가 되지
않는 상황이지만
리모델링 할 때는 그 부분에 대해서
중점적으로 확인을 하셔야 돼요
그렇구나 예전에 우리 반지하 건물들이
많이 있었어요
지역마다
좀 그런 편이고요 그리고 그 당시에
건축한 가치 건축이 된 건물들을 보면
대부분 같은 높이로 건물이
지어졌어요
그래서 어떠한 건물 하나가 좀 많이
노출이 되겠다 하면 그 주변에
건물들은 다 그렇게
높게 많이 노출되어 있어요 확률이 더
높은 거죠
매물을 보실 때
지하 1층에 공부상 인정받아 있어서
당연히 받을 줄 알았지만 나중에 이제
대수선 할 때 어쨌든 허가를 받아야
되기 때문에 그 지하 1층 인정을 못
받을 수도 있다 그래서
매입하기 전에 이렇게 좀 확인을 좀
한번 해 보시는게 좋을 것 같습니다
그래서 지금 2층에 올라왔습니다
그래서 아무래도 이렇게 좀 창을 크게
내니까 이게 사실 면적이 좀 크진
않은데 그래도 되게 좀 커 보이는 거
같아요 지금 저의 한층에 면적이
20평
정도는 좀 가급적이면 상황이 좀 크게
재택을 해줬고요 여기가 기존에
발코니로 썼던 공간인데요 이거 지금
외부 공간으로 바꾸면서 오늘요 바닥
난간 설치하는 작업 때문에 안전당간이
좀 철거가 되겠습니다 사실이 공간에
대해서 되게 고민이 많았어요 너무
협소해서 이거를 어떻게 이제 활용할
수 있을까 2인 테이블 정도는 가능할
것 같아서 그 공간으로 좀 활용하려고
대신에 이제 출입문을 원래는 이렇게
여닫이문으로 그래서 미닫이문으로이
문을 열어 버리면 공간이 또 없어지고
없어지니까 이쪽 공간은
여기도
발코니
공간이죠네 여기는 지금 1층에서 바로
접근할 수 있는 계단이
원래 있었어요
예전에 이제 주택으로 쓸 때는
세대로 들어갈 수 있는 계단들이 있기
때문에 그래서 지금 이렇게 별도로
설치되어 있는 계단들을 중시를 시키고
유지를 하는 것으로
그러니까 했죠 그래서 여기가 어떻게
보면 그 임대할 때 그 출입구가 두
군데여가지고
임대하기가 더 좋은 거 같아요 1층은
바로 도로에서 직접 진입이 되고
2층은 뭐 이쪽 계단을 쓴다든지
3층은
방금 저희가 올랐었던
각 층별로 출입구를 다 분리해 줄
수가 있는 거지
그렇구나
어 여기는 여기는 좋은데요
원래는 3층도 같은
높이인데
실제로 저희가 다 철거를 하고 보니
조금 더 높이가
확보가 돼 있었어요 그리고이 높이를
좀 최대한 활용하기 위해서
원래는 여기가 최상층이에요 그래서
상부에 이제 단열재
고쳐야 되는데
단열재를 붙이는 그 위치를 반대로
옮겨서
옥상에다가
저는 여기 층이 제일 좋은 거 같아요
3층임에도 뭐 물론 접근하려면 계단을
이용해서 올라오셔야 되지만 내부
공간에 이제 활용성을 봤을 때는 여기
이제 내부 계단이 있네요 3층 같은
경우에는 이제 옥상으로 올라가는
계단이
적용이 되어 있습니다
그럼 3층 임차인이 저 옥상도 좀
같이 쓰는데 3층에서만
옥상을 활용할 수 있게
동선을 그렇게 계획을 해 놨어요
아 여기 좋네요
좋은데요
사실 난간을
투시형으로 할지
광고로 좀 높일지
고민을 많이 했었는데 우리 건물이
반지하 느낌의 3승 건물이잖아요
그래서 밖에서 봤을 때 다른
건물들보다 조금
낮아 보여요 그래서 그거를 최대한
높이를 좀 규모를 맞춰주기 위해서
벽을 연장해서
난간 역할을 할 수 있도록
그렇게 구성을 했습니다
[음악]
여기도 괜찮은데
이게
그렇게 높은 건물이 없어 가지고
근데 사실 다른 건물의 지붕이 그렇게
깨끗한 상황이 아니라서
지붕을 보는 것보다는 시선을 위로
열어주는게 좋을 것 같아서 그래서
오히려 아래쪽을 더 막아주니 있습니다
지금 현재 바닥은
방수까지
다이 이후에 마감은 아마
임차인분들께서 같이 진행을 하게 되실
것 같아요 3층
업종에 따라서 조금 달라지긴 하겠지만
뭐 데크 같은 것들이 또 활용하실
수도 있고
저희가 여기 인근에 임대를 좀 몇 개
진행했었는데
임대료가 높아가지고 깜짝 놀랐어요
생각보다 너무 잘 맞춰지고 저는
연남동 올 때마다 진짜 깜짝깜짝
놀래요 오늘 평일 아침인데도 제가
아침에 여기 한 8시 한 반 정도
여기 카페에 있었거든요
외국인 줄 알았어요 다 캐리어 들고
막 갑자기 다 뛰어나와요 여기가
특히 또 이제
게스트하우스나 막 이런게 많이 있어
가지고 또 홍대입구가 그
공항선이 뚫려 있어 가지고
외국인들이 또 많이 이쪽이 인근에
숙소를 잡거든요 여기 인근에
외국인들이 굉장히 좀 많아진 것
같습니다 그리고 주말에 아마 여기
오시면 깜짝 놀라실 거예요
그래서
연트럴파크 상권이 사람들이
많아지니까요 안쪽까지도 계속 좀
확장돼 가지고 이렇게 계속 바뀌고
있는 거 같습니다
요것도 이제 뭐 지금부터 이제 임대를
좀 할 건데 뭐 제가 봤을 때는
그래도 좀 금방 맞춰지지 않을까
그렇게 생각하고 있습니다
네 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
기존의 낡은 주택이었던 거를 이렇게
좀 최대한 활용해서
리모델링한 사례라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다 감사합니다